本期节目与交通银行信用卡最红星期五共同呈现。
每星期五关注交行信用卡。
美食购物加油充电交通出行外卖到家。
直通五折优惠
这期波克来了一位老朋友。
这老朋友我们最近见面的评词比较高。
我刚刚去录了他那个人间辩论小会。
哎你说说把什么感受。
我觉得特别特别特别好。
哎呦妈呀特别好
真的很少用连续三个特别来形容一个好的感觉。
因为我们录的是第二期。
其实这个节目面向公众也无非只有之前的一期。
所以我是希望第二期能和第一期从感觉上有一定的区别。
无论是我们的辩提还是交锋的那种质感。
他对我私心而言就是特别特别有一种爽感在里边。
其实原本斯达是计划让我跟另外一位嘉宾来录制的。
而且他们的计划是。
不要两位嘉宾知道彼此是谁。
就是为什么是这么个设计。
是你自己想逃避别人的过程。
一下就被我们自己的那个同事给说漏了。
然后他们在跟我维稿的过程中。
无意中透露了对方谁。
然后被我精准捕捉到了。
没错
因为这个真的很难不说漏嘴。
因为总会有那种你需要和对方产生一种什么样的关系。
这种讨论
他跟我说对方比较perfect一些辩提的时候。
我就大概猜到了
对
因为我想愿意表达的。
然后又有能力表达的。
还对这个辩提感兴趣的。
是
可能也就是那些人。
对
所以我在设计嘉宾对外的时候。
其实会考虑
就我在设下
如果他们在上场之前完全不知道对方。
可能会在自己的准备的过程当中。
更倾向于深化自己内心的观点。
而不是猜测对方的风格可能是什么？
或者对方的论据可能是什么？
有点类似专注资深的一个感觉。
这个是我的一种歪歪了。
但另外一个可能是。
他会有一种现场的那种戏剧张力。
就比如说如果我不知道是你。
或你不知道是我
那我们上台了
哎
那或者认识或者不认识。
我觉得他都可能会有点。
因为你不见得在真正的世界的生活当中。
你每个辩论的对象都是你认识的人。
很有可能就是路人。
很有可能就是你在餐厅跟人家吵架。
对吧？
那你也不需要认识但你会怎么说。
这可能是我想关注的一个点。
很像相亲
对
对就有点开忙活的意思。
但没说两个人也特别投缘。
所以我觉得对于人家面论小会而言。
就是两个人投缘也好。
不投缘也罢
我其实是开放了一个拍桌子就走人的。
这么一个可能性的。
就是你们节目是五一期间上线的吗？
我记得
我就觉得这事挺有意思的。
然后我看到是你做的节目。
就这么一个形式
我又先看到了一些热门的卡段。
然后我又去点进节目里。
看了一个大概的完整版。
我当时就觉得很好奇。
我想四大又在搞新的事情。
我其实也有想问你。
为什么会想做这么一个形式。
然后为什么要做这件事情。
虽然我没问你
我就答应你要去了。
是
关于这个节目为什么诞生。
其实我们两个私下也没有太了。
从有这个idea到第一期录完。
大概是13天的时间。
觉得它非常非常非常random的一件事情。
本质上这个事是来源于一个平台的期待。
就是因为我跟小红书也一直。
对吧？
无论是比较早期的入住。
还是在导致播
也算是在这个平台里面扎根比较深。
在今年小红书其实有一个。
捧得着大会或者之类的一个颁奖的机制。
所以是在这么一个结枯眼上。
就在考虑说
A4代有没有兴趣去做一个视频播客。
一定程度上算是平台的邀约了。
其实
然后视频播客
这四个字我们放置在两三年之前。
是没有人听说过这个词的。
也不知道是什么？
结果如雨后春水一般。
正如我们此时此刻。
虽然我们颜跟意义上也不是视频播客。
它还是一个播客为大的起点。
你自己的播客是不配视频。
我是完全没有视频。
而且我录播客的原因。
就是因为我要逃避视频。
希望自己可以在
不惜脸不衰的情况之下。
在家里随便就把它给录了。
视频播客其实和我。
从内心里对于播客本身的定义而言。
我还有自己没有办法。
特别圆绒的去理解的什么一个门槛。
这个想法我跟你一模一样。
因为我觉得播客他之所以成立。
就是因为他不需要视频。
没有视频的人会更沉浸式的聊天。
因为你没有一个概念。
没有一个镜头
有人要看我是怎么回事。
就像比如我现在这里点了一个香。
然后如果从视频里你看不见这个香。
你只看见这个烟
就一定会有人觉得你是不是在抽烟。
对吧？
就他会有一个这样子的视觉的误导。
但是实际上如果我们聊天的时候。
他是没有这些干扰的。
没错
你也不用去考虑这些问题。
比如说你跟朋友去约饭。
你跟朋友私下怎么聊天。
如果没有人在拍的话。
你们可以聊得非常非常的顺畅。
你也不会再考虑说。
我聊天还有个节奏的问题。
就是没有人在约饭的时候考虑节奏。
但一旦有人把这个相机举起来。
手机举起来
那个大家就是会增加一些表演感在里边。
我自己选择播客这个内容在体。
我还是想表达了
但第二能不能我们暂时先放松一下。
所以就不去着重考虑拍摄。
但是当这个药院出现的时候。
怎么讲呢？
我身边的人非常非常多的人。
在鼓动我去做一个类似对谈式的视频播客。
正如大家如今能看到的几乎所有视频播客。
都是两个人在有说有笑的聊一些天。
因为我这么多年也算是做了一些访谈类的栏目。
你记得你很多年前找我做的那个节目吗？
那是你第一个访谈节目吗？
那是我第一个访谈节目。
应该还是我前几期的嘉宾之一。
所以你想到现在也十年了。
那是十年了
我记得我在你那个节目里穿的是一条紫色的衣服。
还是跟我今天穿起黄色的衣裳。
还是露满多的
对那个时候是很爱露的。
我还带了个大珠宝。
没错没错
特别傻
那个时候是你好像刚开始要独立做节目的时候。
对
然后我觉得我们一起吃了个饭。
然后你就说了这个想法。
其实我那个时候也不太接受采访的。
但我就觉得你做这个事情好像还蛮好玩的。
对但是那会你已经做了很多很多事情了。
我已经创业了
在做公司了
已经有很多的聊天的本身的素材可以去挖掘了。
但我那个时候的核心生物其实就是经济人。
尤其是一些那会的话题人物的经济人。
所以你当时问我的问题。
基本上是围绕着经济人展开的。
演员偏仇啦
有的没的反正就是那些。
其实是挺八卦的一些话题。
但是节奏很快
我记得我们当时好像聊了半个小时。
还是一个小时
就剪出五六分钟
全是高密度的话题。
所以比较早期的
就是大家都在录比较长视频的时候。
我就在进行所谓短视频采访的这么一个门类。
但那会还没有这个门类。
因为如果有这个门类。
那可能这门类里面只有我这么一家。
你这个叫微宗
对 没错没错没错。
然后再到后来你会发现。
大家会编出中视频。
长视频短视频
视频播客
就是够了一样的名词。
对我来说这些词没有那么关键。
所以当别人在鼓动我去做一个。
一对一这样的视频播客的聊天的时候。
我觉得
哎呦 我不是很想做大家很像的东西。
非常同意
我想做完全不一样的东西。
然后没有人可以抢在我前面来告诉我。
什么叫做视频播客。
所以我来告诉你
什么有可能是视频播客。
于是做了人间辩论小会。
那它从画面上来讲。
它也是很简单的
它也没有太多的那种节目感。
或真人秀的东西
所以基本我们的素材。
两个小时那可能出来一个多时。
那大概和目前主流的视频播客也差不多。
然后它也完全可以听。
我最近因为之前猛的出了很多的。
各位大咖们的视频播客。
哎 你看得多吗？
我看得很少
我听得多
哪怕我用视频平台打开的时候。
我也是听
我一般是干别的事情的时候。
当一个声音在听
我确实听播客最多的场景还是开车。
尤其我在美国读书的时候。
上下学都要40分钟。
而且我经常从LA开去硅谷。
要6个小时
我那一路都是在听播客。
需要补充一些中文的设入。
也会听英文播客
但是确实是驾驶场景。
尤其是独自一员的时候。
我觉得是播客最诚庆式的场景。
或者我去旅行的时候没有信号。
我就会提前下载好播客。
它是一个很好的陪伴。
也是一个思考的过程。
你会觉得现在视频播客。
就是大家的内容同之化比较严重。
很严重
而且就是所谓的访谈。
或者对谈类栏目实在是太多了。
而且有时候你会看见同一个嘉宾。
经常高频的出现在不同人的对话里面。
然后主题也非常的接近。
所以我觉得这就是。
可能在各行各业比较容易出现的。
一种一窝峰的情况。
这就是为什么我看到你的节目的时候。
我觉得我一定要参与一下。
我觉得它很新
所以它不太一样
就很好玩
就是我自己喜欢新东西。
我又喜欢一些有意思的存在。
你准备了多久啊？
咱们这一起录制
我们开了四次会吧？
是不是四次会
因为我其实不太好打听。
从原则上我们是要分别准备的。
因为如果你不能知道我的论点。
那我也不能打开你的消息。
所以我只是节目导演。
偶尔像我透露说
天真那边准备得非常认真。
然后他们就再给我上压力。
就说其实我们已经打了三次电话了。
每次都一个多小时。
是这样的
我们应该前后开过四次会。
每次一个多小时
然后是胡键彪老师都会在。
会做指寶
他会给很多的输入跟修改意见。
然后他会帮我做模拟。
前面其实讨论核心观点。
我们的立论讨论了蛮久的。
反复了好几次
清楚之后就开始练习。
怎么提问啊和怎么样去思考。
你的质询非常精准。
所以你质询的很好。
体现是这不是一个。
比如说谁抄下两个问题。
有三个问题就能实现的一个效果。
它有一个很强的
内在的一个敏锐在里边。
就是它是一个你的思维的能力的。
一个表聚焦的一个反应。
其实质询是我的短板。
我觉得我去系统现在讲一个概念。
我其实反而比较容易讲清楚。
我21年参加奇葩说的时候。
我就有那个深刻的感受。
对攻防的时候我其实不太会。
就我不太会主动发起问题。
不太会攻击
然后不知道问完之后。
下一个问题怎么追问。
因为它不是我日常生活中。
会被练习的场景
它是个纯辩论的场景。
所以这个部分我是有请教键彪。
然后专门他有跟我讲一些逻辑。
但是反正我这个人的特点是。
只要你讲了清楚我就搞得明白。
就是他因为能讲的很清楚。
就是他是你们的外援吗？
算外援也是自己人了。
而且他非常丝滑
就是他跟你聊这些天的时候。
他其实是灵说教杆在里边的。
他不会告诉你
哦这个要这么问
他从来不会讲这样的话。
他都是一步一步引导和一步一步巴掘。
我觉得有可能是此前像奇葩说的那个时代。
他接触了大量
可能毫无辩论经验的这些选手。
然后你要很快的时间进入到一个。
辩论语境里边
所以他应该有自己比较稳健的一些方式方法。
他真的太厉害了
就是无缝连接
临真起手
对
听完马上就有观点。
然后马上就知道这个东西的延展是什么？
前面后面
我在想一个人的怎么对语言的能力能这么强。
他帮我引导出来了。
你知道我这个利润难产到非常夸张。
就是我们这个编题叫做。
为了尊严应不应该自证。
实际上对这个编题我本人是困惑的。
我没有一个特别坚定的释放。
但我又很好奇这件事。
所以我很想跟人家来讨论。
那我基本是主随课遍嘛？
就是人家选什么了。
我来选剩下另外一个释放了。
所以就是应该自证。
然后我难产了很久。
我真的想不出一个特别特别核心的理由。
除了那种情绪是然说。
我不自证真的好憋啊？
你知道吗？
就除了这种态度之类的东西。
我这很难有一个真正很稳定的立场。
所以是在赛前的前两天。
还是前一天晚上
我跟胡锦鸣打了电话。
然后他很丝绊的来帮我整理了一下。
同时他做了很多心灵暗魔的工作。
就是说你也挺有观念的。
你为什么觉得自己没有什么观念。
你知道吗？
就是他觉得这个是可以成立的。
帮我加油打气
同时也确实是帮我很实际的。
来整理出来一些东西。
所以我的好奇是
他的工作是要帮两边都要进行辅导的。
其实不是的
是原本你想自己搞定的。
原本是我和他分别带一个人。
所以我们两个其实。
李英有一点竞技关系在里边的。
理论上也是这样的。
但是这一次不是咱们人选上就有变动吗？
所以我自己上了之后呢？
也劳烦他一下
就多一个耳朵能帮你听一下。
真的很有帮助
你一些搞的是完全靠自己写的。
还是会有一些AI的工具帮助你。
或者其他的外部的输入。
AI只是一个非常小的素材。
像我在立文的时候其实打了这一点。
因为我是真的使用了不同AI工具。
我看一下AI怎么说。
AI其实基本都是一个反方的立场。
很少有AI是正方立场。
几乎没有
但是我真正核心的论点也好。
包括文稿也好
我的一个个人习惯是手写。
而且我是很难真正的使用手机去写。
或者是用电脑去写。
你纯用笔写
我纯是一纸笔
纸笔型选手
我喜欢用纸笔去画脑图。
我经常在飞机上
因为那时候是纸笔的最好场景。
把我要做的事情写出来。
然后把它画成脑图。
我觉得那个是
我现在唯一还用纸笔的一个残留。
还有我就上一语课的时候。
被单词写笔记
其他时候好像
那不就纸笔还是更快一些吗？
纸笔它的转化速度更快。
就是它不会有误解。
我觉得更精准
它会把你的思路
反正就是非常清晰的落在一个纸上。
但它的问题是基本上只有你看得懂。
那个飞沙走石的那种状态。
其实我现在没有想那么好。
我也不知道这个时候该说不该说我。
但是我的一个想法就是。
当未来我们小会的素材在变得逐渐的丰厚。
然后我们每一期大家的利润。
每一期大家的质学问题。
大家的解便
其实都有可以被编辑的。
很完整的一个可以阅读的东西。
然后我觉得它到最后。
无论是一个不可的方式。
还是一个不可的方式。
它都是一个很好的东西。
那你邀请嘉宾的时候记得签一个合同。
要授权给我这个使用权。
得有使用权
我这是我是不是好操心。
我还会思考这个问题。
还有这一步
会的
肯定会让大家授权。
对
那你可以跟我说说这个想法的初衷吗？
就为什么会想到做一个辩论小会。
我是一边做一边回忆。
我大概在我想想两三年前。
在秦岭的家也就是我Panel。
大家吃饭那天喝了点酒。
我忘了我那个期间是在做什么工作。
我现在回忆不太清。
可能是刚开始做直播没多久。
但确确实实是
从仅三天可见之后。
我没有太做所谓节目形态的内容。
后来不就做DV计划。
然后DV计划其实挺好的。
那个节目真的挺好的。
非常非常非常普实的。
所谓视频博客
我看看那个
对
但是没有着手
极其困难
我们是做了很长很长很长时间。
然后才有这样一期。
有一个商业化的机会。
但是整个的这个过程。
其实是一个
我自我评论就是
我很会做内容
但我完全不会赚钱。
因为我觉得DV计划这个形态。
不应该放的尝试频平台。
这个是它跟尝试频的逻辑不一样的。
因为尝试频平台卖的时候。
它是要打包到平台的一些流量政策。
一起学打包卖给客户的。
但你如果没有强明星阵人。
或者强人物指向
不要卖给哪一类客户。
卖给女士用户
还是卖给别人
对
它的销售跟内容是两个部门。
销售部门的人是不理解你的内容。
到底的价值是什么的。
它只能看一些
其他的更表面化的东西。
所以它就没有办法去帮你销售。
是
所以那个阶段就特别的困难。
然后这个困难其实会让大家。
比如说无论你做内容的一种心气。
其实会被一定程度的消磨的。
因为你每个月都是在非常非常亏损的一个状态。
在干这么一个很朴素的事情。
那你当时是没有投资的。
钱都是你自己的
你干别的事挣的钱。
然后养这个钱
完全是在反部到这个栏目里边。
其实栏目本身
它从制作上是没有所谓的硬成本。
我就拿一个DV
我都自己开车
对吧？
也不需要化妆
那这个成本更多体现在。
其实大家团队
就是你要再剪辑
大家在工作
不有工资收入等等。
所以你需要把团队的这一部分。
当做一个成本
把它扭出来
我都是完全亏损的一个状态。
所以这个事情
它就变得非常不可持续。
所以我在秦岭家
当时聊可能
恰好就是在这么一个结构眼上。
为什么会有人间变了小会。
大概三年前我就跟朋友说。
我说哎呀？
我还是觉得
好想搞一个小小的俱乐部。
然后大家就是抽一天晚上。
我们所有人就得聊一个问题。
我们就围绕这一件事。
高度的把它解释清楚。
我不在乎这个台上的人。
有名没名
就是他的名气跟他说话。
有没有道理没有关系。
是
我当时是有这么一个期待的。
就是想做一个线下小沙龙。
之类的这种
因为比如说线下脱口秀他成立。
那线下的一个私变的小峰会。
这个事是不是也有想象力。
我觉得神秘
呀？
然后那会儿就心里。
就留了这么一个念想。
但也迟迟没有启动。
换而言之
我就是花了很长时间。
才果敢的进入到
直播电商这么一个板块。
因为还是想跟商业走得更近一点。
所以你去做这件事情的时候。
是因为
你觉得你的内容跟商业没连接。
或者是他的两个缓解。
对
在我心中
我始终没有办法
把他很有机的组织起来。
其实今年还好一些。
反而到现在我可能从思路上。
理解这件事
包括你刚才提到的。
不同的平台
不同的客户
不同的这个平台的负责人。
制片人
他们需求是不一样的。
我也是逐渐才开始理解这件事。
所以现在
似乎能比原来好一些。
但是当时确实很难把商业和内容。
很好的弄在一块
但也确实在这个情况之下。
所谓的没有客户的影响。
我们的内容被很多人接受。
因为我不需要想广告位的问题。
所以我可以更多的去考虑。
我要跟在跟聊什么？
那现在喜欢我的一些人。
我觉得可能跟当时内容是有关系的。
你喜欢直播卖或这个过程吗？
我个人从情感上很难说喜欢。
我花了很长时间
在不断的理解这件事。
我在不断的理解
我完全理解你说的这个过程。
因为我也都经历过。
对 你也能想像我。
对吧？
就是在那个环境之下。
我刚开始做直播带货的时候。
最大的一个困境就是。
比如这个东西今天卖好了。
卖爆了
你要再卖一遍
我讲到第二遍的时候。
我就会有一种收拾感。
那种表演感一上来的时候。
但确实有人刚进勃勃脚。
对吧？
其实有人他经常没听到。
用户其实不一样
对呀？
然后我对于他的一个解读是这样的。
就是我的那个难受点来源于。
我如果要做直播
我必须
我是把创作变成服务。
创作是创作服务是服务。
我原来是创作型的。
但我今天必须得转化为服务型的。
如果你服务的特别好。
你当然也会在这个行业里面。
有你的名声也好
或有你的收入也好。
无论是价格的服务还是说。
like服务本身。
但我认为我可以服务得很好。
只不过这个服务的机会。
让我放弃了创作的机会。
就是我没有时间去好好想。
我应该去设计些什么？
去写一些什么？
去表达一些什么？
它稍微有点拧吧？
就在这
因为创作的主题表达主题。
它其实是一定程度上。
要以自我为中心的。
就是它得把自己聚焦到最核心的位置。
甚至于自己的内在的主张也好。
人格也好
ego也好
它必须得大
你很难想象一个导演没ego对吧？
就是那是什么画面呢？
就很难想象
所以它必须得有这个东西。
但是服务又让你去掉这个东西。
你还得把你的ego放下。
你得把你以自我为中心的自我主张心。
暂时放到一边
你得以人家的需求为主题。
所以当人家希望我转过去。
给它看看这条裤子背面。
那我就要好好地转过去。
给它转到裤子的背面。
因为我既然干这个了。
和人家有这个需求。
那我就应该服务它。
但只不过这两个业务方向。
就对我而言稍微有点拧吧？
我其实是思考了很久之后。
最后我放弃了做带货这件事情。
因为我那时候想做自己的品牌。
我发现肯定是我带货。
它的效果是最好的。
最直接
对
你选的吗？
你确实对它有感受。
你是真正的一个这个产品的创造者。
所以你对它所懂
你都有理解的
后来我意识到两点。
第一个就是达成销售这个事情。
对我没有那么兴奋。
就是我把它卖出去。
你觉得那个成交不敏感。
我的感受就是
我把对它的这个好处告诉你。
我觉得买卖这个事情。
本身就是一个
你喜欢就买不喜欢拉倒的过程。
我没有想要
你会倒有松弛感
是吧？
在这里面
对 我们不喜欢上一些销售技巧。
但是客户不是这么想的。
是
对所有的需要你卖它的人。
它都会给你准备好。
各种的卖点
销售套路
这个我也非常理解。
我要自己卖东西
我肯定也是这样子。
但我就觉得这个事情本身。
就算你做成了
你也没有快感
你是一种任务感
就是这有个任务
所以我要去完成它。
而且将比这些销售技巧。
我肯定是更欣赏
能直接看到实际价值的产品。
这也是我为什么推荐交通银行信用卡。
最红星期五
它不搞复杂的套路。
只给你确定的安心。
本月消费达标后
下个月就能选一项。
想舞者优惠
覆盖的都是我们每天生活中。
要用的场景
上班通勤
开车加油
晚饭外卖
周末聚餐
而且在世界盃期间。
直通厂还升级了
50元外卖红包优惠。
有机会抽取
让大家更能安心点销业。
具体活动规则
可以到交行信用卡。
外单8APP里了解一下。
15年长期陪伴不是血头。
是一种你好好生活。
我默默支撑的踏实感。
当然
任何提供消费便利的工具。
前提都是你对自己的支付能力。
有清晰的判断
合理使用
量力而行
好说回带货这件事。
后来我就做了一个决定。
就是我希望我的生命中。
不要再花时间去完成任务了。
这个任务我可以理解吧？
这是一些品牌或客户的期待吗？
不
因为其实也没有人给你。
这MV的要求吧？
就我今天卖直播的时候。
我肯定会对这个结果。
至少你有个目标吧？
这样团队才知道该怎么做。
你也知道该怎么做。
然后比如不打成目标。
你是不是就不能下播。
还是你今天就播了。
是管他卖成什么呀？
你就得下播
就这些东西我都要确定好。
确定好我才知道
我的行动该怎么样去完成它。
总归回到这个人生大命题上来讲。
就是我不去做那些。
我想混的事情
你跟董杰聊过这事吗？
我聊过
他是非常享受的
我认为董杰他是一个审美的集合。
是有认真的在生活跟审美的。
我觉得我不是
我生活得很潦草的。
就是我对大部分吃什么用什么？
没有那么？
比如说护肤品
在我脸上的感受跟变化。
我是不太会花时间观察的。
我只有说我用错一个东西的。
比如他让我长包了。
踩雷了我会知道这东西不对。
我经常问这些厉害的。
艺能镜包括冰冰
董老师
我说你用这个跟这个用这个。
你真的能感受到差别吗？
对 他们说有巨大的差别。
这个怎么的人
我说在哪
我感受不到
随时有点先天带货生体。
是
他能妈咀出来这个点。
对 你既没有天分。
然后你又没有成就感。
那你无非是用他赚钱。
对吧？
你就会觉得
你是不是可以做一些你更喜欢的事情。
或者你心中更有价值。
赚钱去赚钱的
你又不是只有这一条路可以选的时候。
你非得干这个吗？
对 我在卖这些东西里面。
我可以说只有一个品类。
我是真正非常非常喜欢的。
就是鞋就运动鞋
所以你才能卖好
对 我也就运动鞋卖得好。
我只有一个品类是我真心喜欢卖的。
就是书跟课
就是付费型
对 这个课程如果我真的觉得他有用。
我就会很想去推荐。
而且我知道他就是会有一定用处的时候。
我就会很强力的
希望真的大家能够给到一些东西。
就还是基本上是一个价值认同。
说实话我觉得比较互付品。
在我看来就有一个。
就是你的预算
你预算多你就买好点的。
你预算不够
你就买个性价比的。
其实差别也没有那么大。
是啊？
有时候互付品买的是一种感受。
包括有时候卖书呢？
买一种氛围
对 很多人买的也不是书的内容。
他买的是一种我学习的状态。
我都会劝他们别买的。
我买的是书价的装饰。
就是咱们这价值上总该摆样东西吧？
就是你买回去如果你真的不看的话。
我觉得就没必要买。
就算了
所以就是我希望大家花钱是花在一种。
不仅是情绪价值上。
而是有实用价值
情绪价值你有太多选择了。
但是你在直播间里面讲这个。
就是不行
对 就卖不动
必须得
你让他本来没有这个需求。
你把这个需求给他撬出来。
你生造出来某一种需求。
告诉他永远缺一个东西。
永远缺一本书
永远缺一瓶互付品。
如果真的就是你要所谓的追求GNV也好。
或者我要当一个无良商人。
加一点银行
所以这个就是我现在思考中的。
一个最大的困境
因为我的本质是个商人。
就是我觉得
我思考任何事情是要有商业避还的。
我做一个东西最后要结果。
这个结果要提前在钱上。
因为提前在钱上
所有的参与者才会有满足感。
这不是说我一个人钱够了就行的事。
那参与的每一个人。
大家都要赚钱掉了。
对
就你除了荣誉感受这些虚的东西之外。
你得赚着钱
这件事我相信了
你曾经跟我说的一句话。
给我带来了极大的震撼。
我说什么？
你当时真的给我幼小的心灵。
带来极大的震撼
我记得是在你家就咱俩闲聊。
歌词大义就是我们。
比如说如果要立一个项目判断标准。
你手上800个项目。
哪个做哪个不做
是怎么判断出来的。
反正你当时给了我一条底线。
就是这个东西不赚钱不做。
对不赚钱你做他干啥。
然后他对我而言是一个震撼。
你知道吗？
我就想不赚钱就不做吗？
然后这是我在工作的时候。
我在做所谓内容的时候。
也在思考的一个问题。
因为比如说你也可以为了调性做事。
你可以为了一个公共的这种形象。
再去做事
我记得我当时也是这么跟你聊的。
就是他并不一定有。
及时的一个直接的价值反馈。
但你的意思是怎么说他来着。
我现在虽然不记得我当时说什么？
但是我的思路应该是没有变化的。
我认为一件事情他能够赚到钱。
说明他有用
就是他的每一个环节。
说明是这个社会价值系统里面都认同的。
就是你整件事情他流通起来。
而不是你单方面觉得他有用。
不是一种自嗨
对
所以我认为赚没赚到钱本身是。
这个事情到底是不是真的有用的一个验证。
但是我们文青真的是这样的。
所以我就自我定义是个商人。
就是我接受
很多人经常说我商人嘴脸。
或者说我做一件事情。
他一定有目的
没有目的
他为什么要嘴脸
那是不是自己还挺高盛的。
我准确讲我是个商人。
而且我因此为容
我没有觉得这不对。
那商人也有很多种。
我很清楚知道我是什么样的商人就好了。
我知道我不是个唯利仕途的商人。
但我的本质一定是个商人。
没错
我不可能做一件
我看不到商业避缓的事情。
包括我训练我所有的播客团队。
就是我喜欢播客
因为我觉得播客是一个完整表达。
我觉得我们现在的社会。
太多的碎片表达
而完整表达它本身有价值。
我其实想要做的事情。
是内容本身可以赚钱。
因为我们现在的内容的赚钱。
其实靠影响力去跟商业的对话。
就是商业客户买单。
但到底内容本身怎么能赚到钱。
你很挑战的
因为大家都认为内容是免费的。
不是因为你有点用。
我才不听你的
所以我经常看到咱们播客平台的。
很多创作者
他做一期收费播客的时候。
那种心态真是战战津津。
他要谨小身为的
把内容做到足够好。
他才好意思收一点钱。
这个心态我觉得对创作者来说。
我肯定是很尊重的。
但是我觉得反映出来。
就是大家真的觉得内容不值钱。
我为什么要为听你一个东西。
讲个故事
你做一件事我就要付费给你。
我之前卖过一个
我忘记一块还是三块了。
就是我的播客付费单期。
那个播客可能是30秒。
是我自己唱一首歌。
叫做《飞盘》
啊 《飞盘》之类的。
就是我唱《飞盘》
哦 《飞盘》
听你这几句不太值一块钱。
大概是一块钱
然后因为姜斯坦的播客叫姜斯坦。
整个都是一个免费的状态。
只有个别的几期分外。
叫做歌酒
是我付费播客
歌酒就是歌韭菜的那个歌韭。
我以为是边喝酒边唱歌呢？
没有想到是歌韭菜。
这是歌韭菜
我告诉大家我要歌韭菜了。
韭菜现在是不是长得又壮又肥。
那我先来歌一歌
你都得意图先行对吧？
你得告诉大家
我这是一个游戏
你们愿意就来参与。
被我歌一下
其实是的
换句话说
我觉得大家就是对我好。
给我打个小红包
就是那个感觉
所以它其实有点像是我跟。
我的听众在这玩呢？
别人也不理解
对吧 花一块钱听。
姜斯坦唱三十秒《飞盘》
但是也没关系
就是我跟那伙玩呢？
叫歌酒
也雪转好几千吧？
这个问题的本质就是。
这是一种有趣的互动。
它不是内容本身可以卖成价。
而且你不可能靠这个来生存。
对 所以我觉得我个人。
肯定是没有能力解决。
怎么就让内容之前这个问题。
这是一个长期的
真的很难
很难
但是我特别愤愤不平的是。
很多知识付费
他们那课根本就不好。
就没有观点
没有效果
然后没有用
那你认识这些人本人吗？
有一些认识有些不认识。
那你会跟他们私下聊天。
会的
或者说我觉得你的这个产品。
更多的可能是
能销售出去是因为用户。
对需求的恐惧
我不喜欢所有利用恐惧感。
去赚钱的方式
但大部分能卖出去的东西。
好像都在利用这个东西。
你不学这个你就完了。
你得怎么样
我就很反感这个东西。
我的视角
但是你觉得很生效。
对 我知道
而且很暴力
所以我才难受
难受是你觉得不对的东西。
被你认同的系统赋予的价值。
我刚不是跟你说
我觉得商业是结果吗？
明白
我不认同这个事情本身的价值。
但是这个系统又给予了它价值。
所以我自己也在这个里面在寻找。
我是否能找到一条正确的方式。
至少就是我认同的方式。
它的商业的过程
结果定价一系列的东西。
它都是合理的
我不知道
但是我在做
你觉得一个人的道德感是横定的吗？
还是说他会因为
商业价值高高低低。
你的道德会随之
会变换
因为我见过那种教授。
或者是他没有赚过钱的。
他之前道德感很高。
但是他的道德感很快会被钱击毁。
当这个钱真的是没见过的时候。
对超过他的任职
他发现原来这么干。
可以挣出这么多钱的时候。
道德感就崩溃了
但我也见过
就是他的道德标准。
从来没有被金钱改变过的人。
我也见过能够在这套系统里自洽的人。
我们艺人行业很多。
一个人可能谁都不是一个小孩。
但他后来变成了很厉害的人。
可以赚到很多钱
你能看到很多变化的。
就是在金钱 在名利。
在放大气下的人的变化。
这本身也是人性
这里没有对错
我没有认为他们就变了。
变化就变坏了
因为有几个人可以。
有几个人可以雇手。
而雇手本身就一定是对的。
但是我们还是很本能的。
心上一个人始终能守住。
对吧？
或者守住
我觉得恒定是一件很了不起的事情。
就你能形成自己的价值系统。
并且你恒定的守卫着它。
我觉得我的价值系统就非常恒定。
如果以我们第一次录节目为一个标志。
那到现在这十年
我真的觉得你的思维也好。
你的判断方式也好。
没有一个特别那样的变化。
还是很稳定的一个人。
还是说那会你已经很稳定了。
我觉得人就有在真正的选择中。
你才知道自己是谁。
这是我一直非常底层的一个观点。
因为我面对过很多很大的一个钱的选择。
太多次了
从我做经济人
做那么多所谓的顶流的经济人的时候。
我从未选过
我从那个时候我就知道了。
就你经历过一个大的挑战之后。
这些日常的小挑战就对你不是事了。
但是那个大的挑战的选择。
它会定义你是谁
你这么多年会有那种三观。
我不说震碎吧？
但是会产生一个极大的震动那种事件吗？
有的
就是比如说我们的红行会有那种。
比如说它是你的经纪人。
它对外签了一个合同。
一千万
它告诉你五百万
那五百万它黑了
然后就五百万还要抽你的成。
我第一不理解
这样很多艺人是知道的。
我只能理解他们可能有一些其他的原因。
所以他没办法举报或者走法律程序。
第二这样的人
他可能还一直在签新的人。
结果永远不断地有人被骗。
同时从业者而言
很多人会因为这样的人存在。
觉得我也可以这样。
就是我认为他的饿是做了一个非常不好的示范。
大家都这样
我也可以这样
我觉得我也没有什么很高尚的道德。
但是我肯定是非常清楚什么叫做。
职业底线
就不能赚的钱
我觉得可赚可不赚的钱。
你在一些没钱的时候你可以去赚。
但是不可赚的钱
在任何时候都不可赚。
这是我的底线
觉得未来会还回去吗？
你比如说像他们赚的这种黑心。
我认为会
他只是时候未到
这是最普输的一句话。
当我是坚信这件事情的。
而事实上虽都我们年龄的增长。
很多事情你会看见周期。
就是有一些人一时间春风得意。
然后他名利双收
但再过一阵子他就没了。
他可能消失得很快。
影视行业的这个周期。
可谓也是众所周知吧？
你对此的心态是什么呢？
你会再比我
所有人都说这是影视行业。
或娱乐行业的一个偏寒冬。
这么一个状态之下。
去寻找
或者说你早在此前。
就很早就去寻找别的机会了。
我认为这不是寒冬。
这是冰川期
就是冰封
我那天看了地球的冰川期的一个视频。
比如地球的冰川期可能会有一亿年。
然后非冰川期可能有十几亿年。
咱们地球好像是60多亿年。
61年左右吧？
它中间经历了三个冰川期。
冰川期就是万物灭亡。
只有一些微生物可能会留下来。
然后从新开始一个轮回生命。
从新生长
我不知道我这两年看了很多关于宇宙。
地球这些大概念的时候。
你会觉得生命非常不值一提。
我说它的不值一提不是指它不宝贵。
而是你个人的喜怒哀乐。
行业的心衰
都不是事儿什么的。
这都是一个大规律里的非常小的事件。
你都只能拿宇宙的视角。
才能安抚我们的那些。
这个也太不残酷了。
个体来讲
你除了接受适应之外。
你没有任何一个选择。
你的所有的抱怨不甘心。
这环境对你有消极影响。
没有
从未
所以你是如何经历了这个周期。
或者说在这个周期里边。
寻找到自己另外一种生活方式呢？
就是第一你
就像我很早就看见。
我2020年的时候我们公司就做大变革了。
那个时候影视行业还是非常好的时候。
我就开始去做我的个人IP。
开始做产品
我的大马女装开始做短视频。
去做新增业务了
而事实也证明
后来由于我没有了。
直播短视频的新增业务。
我们公司业绩才没有往下走。
然后在前两年短剧最流行的时候。
所有人都在做短剧的时候。
或者觉得要去做短剧。
说我研究了一下短剧。
我对短剧的底层逻辑非常不认同。
就是第一
它在利用焦虑
在贩卖
我们它在说是一样的。
对
就是它是先让你免费看几集。
看到那个坑劫的时候。
你必须得收费
它因为卡了你的短板。
我就不喜欢这个东西。
所以我从价值观上不认同。
第二个
我认为它越是利用情绪化制造的东西。
它会非常容易吸引你。
但你也非常容易放弃它。
所以我觉得短剧就是一个过渡型产品。
它是不具备长久生命力的。
所以你是研究了一下。
对
因为从理论上而言。
你想做这个对你来说是很顺的吗？
是
就是我知道我如果快速进场。
我可能能赚一笔快速离场。
但我不想做这样的事情。
我可以去做
但我不想做
就是我判断它就是一个快进快出的事情。
当然有赚着钱的公司。
但是现在基本上
这人短剧被AI短剧快速叠带了。
AI短剧
接下来也会被新的产品叠带掉。
因为我就是觉得这个产品本身。
是一个有点像新分技。
它是一种非必须的情绪产品。
它会快速让你嗨起来。
但是嗨一旦消遣之后你会不回头。
它不像影视剧
我这一阵子没看电影。
我走进电影院
我可能还是会被一部好电影吸引住。
因为那是一种情感的需求。
但是短剧它不是情感需求。
它是情绪需求
情绪需求的产品是很快会被叠带掉的。
所以这是当时我的行业做过的判断。
而且我经常在公开场合讲这话。
这都可能短剧行业人不太好吧？
但是我确实是我的观点。
所以我从那个时候一直在讲这个观点。
包括我在20年在研究直播的时候。
我就觉得直播唯一的出路是内容直播。
就是你有好的内容带来的大家的年性。
直播本身也是内容的设计。
你怎么选品
你用什么样方式卖货。
叫卖式的直播
我也认为是个意识的产品。
是大家看个热闹
就广场上有人在那表演。
你走回去看个热闹。
但之后你一定会变的。
其实真正做的好的主播都是在做内容。
不是在做叫卖
所以最后回到我觉得是跟人的需求。
本身相关的
比如你说人间辩论小会这个节目。
我不觉得说看辩论是个杠须。
但是听观点是个杠须。
在观点里面去理解我怎么样去。
树立价值观以及表达方式。
我认为是个杠须
所以我觉得这个东西会一直存在。
就是听一些有趣的人聊天。
然后很多的
就像现在视频播客的。
以后撑损般
我也觉得有一些人可能是觉得。
这是个热闹点
那平台有扶持
然后有话题有关注。
我们大家都来做这个事情。
很多的热门的东西都是。
一时进一对人进
然后内卷走掉
这个行业之后就被毁掉。
有很多这样的事情。
从生产制造业到产品。
品牌再到内容都有这样的事情。
但没关系
OK这个世界这样发生可以。
但你要怎么活
你要成为这样一个快进快出的人吗？
还是你要做自己的。
你觉得一个成功的商人和封口。
到关系应该是什么样。
我觉得是你本来想做的这件事情。
是你认定的事情
它正好迎来了封口。
你就能成功
而不是追着一个封口。
对不是追着一个封口。
是
我觉得追着封口去成功的人。
他都很短
因为封没了你就没了。
而封本身就是一刃一刃的。
所以这个事情的本质就是这样子。
比如说我研究完短之后。
我觉得它从内容到形式。
都不是我想做的
真正对人有价值的内容。
其实你也不爱看这个东西。
我也点看不了
我能看个一级两级。
就理解完了
我就觉得好无聊
我就不看了
但是我也理解对这个东西有需求的人。
它就是一个情绪放松。
就像你需要做个按摩一样。
我已经随处可见
你在大街上走过任何一个。
如果还有人坐在
比如说公园的长椅上。
或者是列车的某一个车厢里边。
就是在远远不断的看短去。
我妈就一直看
我觉得如果能稳定。
在那看还是OK的。
我看到外卖员在
等红鱼灯的时候
再看短去
就是这个世界的大家也。
对 也在看东西
就首先我觉得这样很危险。
但是没有想到
原来我以为自己是懂内容的。
但是这个是我完全没有办法解释的。
你仔细想也能解释了。
但是也不想去
内容本质都是满足不同人群的需求的。
内容是什么吗？
你讲到那么高达上没有意义。
它其实无非就是一种感受需求。
它需要一些具体的表达方式。
我好奇
这个东西真的比大自然的风景更好看吗？
但不是每个人都有机会走进去大自然。
看到风景
这你抬在头
比如说就看看你今天感受一下。
今天的演热是吧？
好像我也没有必要在路上走的时候。
我一边走到咱们园区里边。
一边就看那个
但我这个就有点姿态了。
那我能感觉到
我是这么看的
就是有的人他的习惯是被动接收。
就是今天这个系统给他什么东西。
他接收到
然后他判断一下他喜不喜欢。
如果今天有一个系统。
把他带去大自然
他可能也发觉是喜欢的。
他会去创造
就像我
我原来不爱运动
没有人把我带进运动那个系统的时候。
因为我对他都是想象。
运动好不了
运动弄得满身是汗。
运动会把我的妆弄花。
你没有一个人或者一个契机。
把你带进那个系统的时候。
你没法抬头看铁
是
所以你只是一种想象。
所以想象很容易存在在批判。
说到封口这个问题。
我真的曾经也慌到。
自己会在小红双去看相关的人在那。
分析封口这样的视频。
什么造成你的慌张。
财务问题
个人和公司的财务问题。
由于我实在太过不会经伤了。
所以导致大家跟我只有苦日子要过。
你是哪一年创业的算。
我基本大学毕业里就开始了。
但也一直没有真正的。
比如说带着大家共同富裕。
也没有真正意义上实现。
这么多年折腾下来。
反正把自己能折腾到。
在小康水平上
大概就是这样
但你要至于说
我们所有人跟着江南能增地。
我在这是有道德的愧疚感的。
那你觉得大家为什么跟着你。
那肯定还是有我的一些小优点吧？
我至少从江西达工作室。
出去的人在别地的薪资可能是三倍。
如果从这个角度而言。
收入其实不用太丑的。
比如说做直播
到后来做运动相关的东西。
大家还是摆摆胖胖的把自己养的。
只不过没有到那种。
特别特别的有安全感。
别什么都不用丑
始终就是没有过的一个状态。
所以当财务上会有这样的。
一个很实际的问题的时候。
因为小红书他就是能刷到。
不知名的某男子或某女子。
在一个老板间坎坎而坎。
他对于封口的理解。
其实我感觉都是演员啊？
但是我居然那个视频我看进去了。
我发现人没有一个特别固定的形象。
人的形象是由所有他。
此时此刻的处境的一个集合体。
非常准确
我当时就是一个需要。
极大解决才无问题的这么一个处境。
于是我当时没有那些。
风华雪月
也没有在看运动的内容。
我在看内容是一个不知名的。
谁在那里讲他对于封口的理解。
然后我在这
嗯有道理有道理有道理。
那个视频我刷完之后。
我瞬间觉得自己特别的可悲。
而且这些事也没有很遥远。
这些事可能也无非就是。
两年之前的事情
我真的觉得我自己好可悲。
我怎么从那样一个心气特别高的人。
或者说大家至少觉得。
我心气是挺高的
觉得我好像一直都有一个态度。
或有一种形象在这个世界上存在着。
怎么他自己偷偷在看这种东西呢？
哎呀我就是有这样的一个意想。
哎呀就是又瞬间觉得特别的可悲。
又很难过
但是日子
你那个时候可以面对自己的这种挫败感吗？
因为你今天来讲的时候。
我感觉你是完全可以面对的东西。
对呀其实当时也能面对。
当时谁若跟我提这件事的时候。
我不会有什么害臊或者怎么样的。
因为我清楚我的长短板。
我长板也可以挺长的。
所以我短板
那可能就是对商业的理解。
非常之出击
那你会想过让去读个生学院什么这种。
我让其领去呀？
他去就行了对吧？
我觉得逼我去搞
我肯定不会搞懂的东西。
就是在耽误所有人。
所以我觉得我之前的问题就出现在。
我明明没有很懂商业。
但是我却掌握着公司商业运营层面上的最高权利。
这件事就是一个权利给错人了。
所以不应该我去想这个问题。
或者我去管这个问题。
我应该管的就是这个字体应该是什么样。
这字号应该是什么样的。
这个应该这么拍还是应该那么拍。
因为这个东西我擅长。
这个东西我也喜欢。
所以我到后来才发现。
当我真正的在把自己的意识和价值。
非常非常自信的放在我自己认为的常处里面。
我的常处才真正的有可能成为常处。
否则我的常处只是一种自以为有的特点。
但你其实都没有实践过。
我觉得你刚说这段其实就是商业的本质。
哦
一下被我点创了
是什么呢？
商业的本质就是把人的常处放在真正需要他的地方。
然后提供给需要他的人。
一切都是真实的需求。
我觉得那些长久的能把生意做好的人。
就是因为他在做他擅长些喜欢的事情。
而这些事情是被人真实的需要的。
你一直在一个自己舒适的生态位里面吗？
就是在商业环境之下。
会有一些不舒适的时刻。
但是大体而言都是。
大体而言是比较舒服的。
比如说我也会遇到一些危机。
类似于可能很多艺人都离开我了。
我该怎么办
或者我重要的艺人。
重要的收入来源
算是具体的业务吗？
或者具体的事吗？
但是从身位上而言。
你其实一直都是把自己放在一个相对准确的位置上。
对
这个过程当中没有人打压你吗？
我觉得会发生很多状态。
但他打压不了我
就像比如说我刚开始去做短视频的时候。
我们行业的各种大佬就会经常嘲讽我。
自己吃饭啊喝酒的时候就会说。
你杨丁这有病啊？
他自己去泡头露面干嘛？
会讲这些东西
就一些声音
对 他们也试图打压我。
我说小杨啊你不应该怎么怎么样啊？
就是这种
你说这种打压对他们有什么好处呢？
因为你的出现颠覆了他们对这件事情。
和这个定位的认知。
他其实不是在针对你。
他就一瞧着了对他的那些秩序。
他就觉得你不该存在。
然后你不应该这样子干事。
他甚至是为你好
他会觉得你这样做会有反视。
他不一定是恶意的。
但他本身是一种打压。
但是他确实打压不了我。
我还没遇到过打压不了我的人。
可能没有
因为我其实挺确定的知道我在干什么？
而且我还能接受我不成功。
我能接受我干不好。
我觉得结果本身已经可以说明问题了。
就不需要再有一个。
一个人是如何
比如说又珍惜自己的面子。
还是说你不珍惜面子。
我觉得你挺珍惜面子的。
就是又能珍惜自己的面子。
又能接受失败
这个是怎么共存的。
面对真相
大部分人是没有能力面对真相。
比如说我今天录播课。
我举例
我也会邀请很多人。
他们拒绝我
即便我的播课
今天已经做的这么有影响力了。
你不一定百发百众。
对 他拒绝你的原因。
可能也跟你没有太大关系。
他就是不想做这个事。
他不想泡头轮面
或者他确实觉得你不行。
你不配
也是有的
就是你能否面对这件事情。
比如人家拒绝你
你是会恼羞成怒
还是你会
肯定是会有不爽感。
但这个不爽感的背后。
你能否面对它
我觉得真相是一切问题的钥匙。
真相特别重要
就是你愿不愿意知道。
因为我在某些场合。
你会背受尊重
大家把你捧得很高。
没错
在某些场合
你就是个Nobody。
比如呢？
宾居院看病
你得劳劳实际排队。
对
就是你没有任何的特殊性。
但有的人不是的
他是一定要去创造自己的特殊性的。
他要去找人
去通过各种
他没有办法接受自己。
对
就在我看来
你排个队吧？
干嘛非得去怎么样。
是
而且有的时候
我会受到一些优待的时候。
我会特别的不好意思。
就是我觉得好像
我这不就是个这么简单的事吗？
何必遮腾成这个样子的。
其实对
被别人嫁在那儿
你本人也是会尴尬的。
就说也会有一个
对我不舒适
但有的人是非常要那个的。
就是很多人比如吃饭。
是一定要进包间的。
在这个大厅
他就会觉得
这不是我来的地方。
我是完全
哪都行的路边都行的人。
是啊？
人还是随和点好
真的
就很多人会被自己嫁住。
比如他觉得他是个谁。
他是个大佬
我经常听到有人跟我说。
像我这样的大佬
然后他后面说什么？
我走进不进去了
而他会自称大佬
像我这样的行业大佬。
怎么怎么样
就是你知道吗？
这话我相信
是有太多人在他耳边说过。
说过之后他就觉得。
我是行业大佬
所以他们到后来
比如说
你像这么多大佬
他们在公共舆论上。
有所谓翻车
或者什么的
我觉得都是有机可寻的。
就比如他其实打心底。
他从来没有站在公众的角度。
去理解他
因为现在的宇境
尤其是公共宇境
他是非常平权的
就是他没有权威感。
不是因为是你说了这个话。
大家就觉得我就得听你的。
你是大佬
没有给过我一分钱。
所以我对吧？
我也不用多梦那个你。
对
就是但是很多人是活在那个。
就语序里的
就是我是个谁
所以我说的话就该被认同。
且我都掏心掏肺跟你说了。
你竟然还质疑我
就是他们接受不了。
公众的真实情绪
其实我觉得都翻车在这个点上。
就是你先把自己
架在了某个位置上。
没错
那也有评论说
你也有这种高卫感。
我觉得会有
这个事情是
你习惯了之后的不觉察。
我有时候会说话也会。
你就该怎么干
或者你就该那么干。
当你指点江山的时候。
尤其是你觉得你的出发点。
是好意的时候
你就会忘记
而且你的工作职责里面。
就是说很大一部分。
就是要指点江山
对吧你是老板
你不指点这也不太行。
对
但是我觉得这种感受。
我不认为都是不好的批评。
就是他如果提出这种感受来说。
的话
我觉得这是他真实的感受。
对
这个真实的感受
就是反映了一种真实的情绪。
所以你会自省吗？
我会
原来我这样说话
因为当我发现我的意图。
跟我传递出的东西。
不一致的时候
我觉得中间肯定是。
为什么折叠了一下。
那个折叠
就往往是你的自以为是。
我觉得这是急需要警醒的。
我没有认为人在公众。
表达上可以不翻车。
只是翻车之后
你会认真的思考
我哪里的问题
还是你非要倔强的。
觉得老子就是没错。
错的都是你们
这是两件事情
我认为人的能是否。
动态的成长
他就取决于
你是否会真实的接受真相。
但真相有好多方面。
就是每个人的真相的版本。
其实也会稍有区别。
换句话说
至于不同的角色
他看到的真相可能也不一样。
就比如人家觉得
你这个话
为什么会带着优越感。
或怎么地
但你心里知道
我没觉得我自己优越。
这就是我们今天
讨论的要不要自贼。
哪个真相才是真相。
或我现在我应该守住的是。
我相信我自己
还是说我把所有人的意见。
都纳入为意见
就是我怎么判断
就是比如有人在跟我说。
你刚才那件讲话的时候。
有优越感
我就会自喜一下
我有没有优越感
我如果确实觉得
我当时讲这话的时候。
清帅了或者带着一种。
我就是比你懂得心态说的。
我就会提醒自己
下次不要这样
然后我也不会跟这个人解释说。
你对我讲的很重要。
我接收到了
我下次会改
我不会这样做
但是我会心里觉察到。
我那一刻确实是这样子想。
然后我觉得我这样子不好。
我不喜欢
那我要去调整
但是我没觉得
我是那样想的
我觉得我其实
可能你放大了我的。
或者你夸张了我
那我就OK
它其实是自己的过程。
其实什么叫自恰
自恰不是你
就是你自己觉得
你是不是舒服
你是不是自在
你是不是按照
你想要的生活方式。
去过着你想要的日子。
你看咱俩
就是在这种自恰的话题之下。
至少大家觉得
我们还挺不一样的。
一个是很自恰的
一个是
至少它看起来很拧吧的。
你看起来拧吧？
很多人说我拧吧？
然后我就很想给你讨论这事。
我也没觉得你拧吧？
很多人觉得
哎呦江森南怎么过得这么？
怎么样
他们从什么痕迹来判断。
你是拧吧的
可能我说话会怂奸吧？
我不知道啊？
那个叫扭捏吧？
你不是拧吧？
对扭捏做他
我星星做他
我都承认啊？
我很扭捏做他的一个人。
我也是的
对呀？
就是很喜欢这样
很好啊？
但那种拧吧？
我不知道
我觉得
我猜测一下
有没有可能是
他想象
他如果过我这样的生活。
或者我这样的形象。
或表达
他会不太知道该怎么？
处理这个状况
是他没有办法替我来。
想象这个事该怎么弄。
因为我遇到的一些。
可能每个人都不太一样啊？
但是咱遇到的一些。
能会涉及到比较
怎么说呢？
敏感性
之类的
就是他替我担心
我能这么说吗？
替我拧吧？
替我担心
我觉得所谓的拧吧？
通常是他认为
当你有这些表现的时候。
你在背后是什么？
而他认为你那个背后的东西。
跟你的表现不一致的时候。
他就够判定为你是拧吧的。
但我挺一致的
我特别一致
而且我是啥都往外说的人。
我其实没有什么秘密的人。
就比如说一个人有钱。
但是他花钱非常省。
大家可能不会赞美他。
是一个节约的人
大家会觉得你拧吧？
因为在大家的观点里面。
对 你有钱就该好好花钱。
这个可能就叫你拧吧？
其实就是你的行为。
跟社会共识之间的。
有区别
所以我就觉得还好。
完了我觉得你不拧吧？
如果是一个拧吧的人。
我通常不会在他面前说真话。
你怕伤害他吗？
不不不 我就觉得累。
你知道他大概会误解你。
有哪种人士你会
比如说他找你来交流。
你会挡掉
或者说你会退却
或者你会稍微扶眼一点。
第一种人我觉得这个人。
言行非常的不一致。
虚伪
对 我前几天还评价了一个人。
我一个朋友要去跟他有一个交流。
然后他问我怎么看这个人。
他都没问我
我主动说
我说他是给我找不到优点的人类。
公共人物吗？
有一点小名气吧？
然后他说你这么不喜欢他吗？
我说对啊？
他说他得罪你吗？
我说没有啊？
他对我挺好的
我纯粹的就是
客观的不喜欢他而已。
对 我认真的思考我这个人。
有任何优点
我没找到
但你不怕这个话传出去。
我特别希望他知道。
这样子他不要误解。
我们是朋友最好
就他不要接近我
oh my god。
但是他没有得罪你。
他没得罪我
你是纯纯不喜欢他。
纯不喜欢
就是不喜欢
一会儿录完
我私下你能跟我讲这个。
可以可以可以
好的
我没有义务喜欢每个人。
那是
但我有权利表达我不喜欢。
所以我就可以尽管的说。
对
所以你首先你不喜欢虚伪的人。
我觉得严刑不一致是最可怕的一件事情。
没错
就是这个人会让你自己痛苦的同事。
造成遭遭所有人的痛苦。
所以这样的人我就会越离。
就是拒绝跟他们的一切。
可能性的交流
对会害了你的
然后有一些工作场合。
不得不接触的时候。
我就会戴上我的社交面具。
你的社交面具是笑的还是不笑的。
笑的笑的
哦真的很好啊？
哦太好了谢谢你
你好假
不提供任何有效内容的。
你刚才你那一笑是我从来没有见过。
对对对这个笑好假。
是是是
我甚至就希望对方觉察到我在敷衍他。
这样子就不要再把话提起一下去了。
就是没有内容的只给一些口气。
在公司会这样吗？
不会
为什么要在公司这样。
我想什么时候我有这种敷衍感呢？
我对所有没话找话和假装在说话。
我会非常非常过敏。
因为我很客观的总结。
最近几年我一个工作状态是。
镜头一开
需要我高密度的给信息。
需要我说真的话
需要让这个聊天真正的发生。
于是当这个摄像机关掉的时候。
我往往是非常沉默的。
我是不说话的
我不会在微信聊闲天。
我也很少真正的跟人去约饭。
我是相对来说所必的一个状态。
那如果在这个我自己聊养的时候。
你突然间找过来跟我说一些。
肆有弱无的话
就是没有真正的信息在里边。
其实在装饰这个空气我就特别难受。
所以一个相对来说偏客套。
到公关的那种场合。
我就不太行
人家跟我说什么我就。
就我现在的做法就是努力的。
让每一个我去的场合。
都做成我自己的样子。
比如我经常会参加一些晚宴。
我就会讲很多真话。
然后大家过去说你讲话怎么讲。
但我就觉得我今天来了。
既然坐在这里了
我要在自己做两个小时。
我可不想让自己两个小时不舒服。
你会比如说这两个小时。
你没有在讲那几句话。
你也不说话的时候有吗？
就是如果你不融入。
你就保持沉默
你会有这种时刻吗？
没有
我可以选择不去
我去了
就要讲话
对
就要自在
短暂的不舒服
我可以忍受
就比如说我今天可能在地铁上。
碰到一个人
我就要跟他挤两站路。
我OK的
但我要跟这人待两个小时。
这是很长的时间
我要舒服的
如果很不舒服
我就提前退场
或者回到一个我自己舒适的环境里去。
我都说我去参加一个局面。
比如说大家在一起玩。
我今天的气场很不对。
我很不舒适
我也知道比如我们大家打牌。
我走了并不影响这个牌局。
我就会走
我就会让自己离开那个不舒适的环境里面。
就不会强迫自己
不强迫自己
不让自己难受
对
那个不舒适会又让你局促。
然后又让你尴尬
我不想
你这种心态是发生在你。
有了如今的社会地位之后。
从小就是
这是一种出场设置。
这是一种自我意识觉醒之后的。
对自己的保护
因为你知道刚才我们的聊这个。
大家都会觉得
那是挺爽的
但是
那是因为你
因为我经常说一些观点。
大家都说因为你有钱。
因为你成功了
因为你有名
所以我面对这种想法的时候。
我觉得你可以这样简单结论。
但是你这样简单结论之后。
你得不到任何东西。
但本质
问我很清楚我的所谓来实录。
我知道是因为我这样的性格。
才让我变成了今天的我。
而不是因为我所拥有了什么？
我才可以这样做
其实是一个因果关系。
因为我是一个这样的人。
所以我交道的是真朋友。
ok
所以我要么不叫朋友。
交道的都是真朋友。
ok
然后我因为是这样的人。
所以我就活得挺自在。
是
你刚刚说你能接受失败。
但我理解的这个失败。
至少在我的认认之内。
你是能够接受一个项目的失败。
或者你做的一个事业。
的一个板块的失败。
那有哪种所谓彻底的。
无法接受的失败
我没经历我不知道。
我经历的时刻
我才知道我能不能接受。
但是我大概率觉得我能。
能接受
因为你不能接受
你就是痛苦
你失败了
你又不能改变
你不就是痛苦吗？
对
那你不接受你能咋样呢？
不接受不是自己难受吗？
其实所有的接受是一种。
对自己最好的放过。
接受了
重新开始呗
这件事不干了呗
接受了
ok
我这个游戏结束了。
你不接受你在干啥。
你在对抗什么？
因为艺人就是高高低低的。
至少在自己的职业轨迹里面。
是非常常见的一件事情吗？
有没有那种艺人
比如说他进入到了。
一个事业的低谷
或者怎么的
是那种全是无法接受的。
因为他有落差
有的
然后他就开始责怪他人。
就是因为你们让我干了什么？
就是因为谁是谁
在那个时刻怎么样。
那你是怎么？
比如说你是怎么解释。
你为什么现在在低谷里的。
你会跟他分析这个问题吗？
我会分析
但不是你分析哪怕准确了。
他都能接受的
有的人他有情绪之后。
然后慢慢回归真相。
有的人是一直不行的。
那结局就是他会越来越差。
谁都帮不了他
因为他一直在归外赢。
就是因为行业变了。
公司变了
就是因为你变了
就是因为我周遭了什么什么人。
他觉得他好好的
对
他觉得他一切都是好的。
他没有什么问题
或者即便我有问题。
更大的问题也是你。
一旦经用这种叙事之后。
你很难
很危险
对
你其实就是一种失控的。
像一个弹珠划向了。
某一种失去的轨道一样的。
我再八卦一点
因为艺人除了
他和公司之间的关系。
或者和经纪人之间的关系。
就和家人也有很大的关系。
对
家人父母或者伴侣等等。
就是会在他们的
艺人的这种职业生命里面。
发挥什么样的作用。
我认为他本质是一样的。
有的人谈个恋爱
可能事业就毁了
因为他会特别受到对象的干扰。
有的人可能是家里人。
这个干扰可能会一直存在。
其实本质还是你有没有能力。
处理关系
你周遭的人
也有的人可能签这个公司就红。
签那个公司就不红。
其实都是你的能力。
是一种外在赋予你的机会。
还是你自己本身的能力。
真正有能力的人
他就是穿越这些
但大部分人是没有这个能力的。
他就是被一些事情影响。
这就是人世间的痛苦。
假设我们所有这一档览目的听众。
全都是艺人
你说是明星
艺人
对
就是你觉得到最后真正的。
在你视角之下
最成功的那些艺人。
他们有什么共同特质。
第一喜欢自己
第二共情他人
爱自己爱他人
就是我举个例子
我最喜欢的艺人之一宋家。
他就是一个能量很足的人。
他很喜欢自己
但同时他很尊重别人的感受。
不要他从来不知道。
他不会因为喜欢自己说。
你们就都得等我
因为我最重要
他不是的
他对每个人都很客气。
很礼貌
他从小就是对每一个喜欢他的人。
他的粉丝
他都极其的尊重和有礼貌。
就是你在他生活里的所有细节。
你都看到这个人不是演的。
他是内心的尊重
对大家好
他希望能对大家好。
他尽所能的对大家好。
我经常从他身上
切各种项链
猪串
就是他就觉得
你喜欢
你是我的朋友
那我就分享给你
就很大方
这些东西是装不来的。
我特别不喜欢那种。
表面上人们狗样的。
但是对工作人员
对服务人员态度很差的人。
这种人很多
讲真很多
这种人我就不交往。
不签约不合作
你可以这样
但你别跟我成为朋友。
所以你签人之前
你是先跟他比如说约个饭。
或者说
那肯定会有很多过程。
慢慢适应跟了解的过程。
我理解人有情绪
你有情绪
你会有那种冲动签人的时候。
没有
都是要了解的
因为这是一个长期合作伙伴关系。
他不是一个咱们一交易一次的。
就是见一面终身不见的关系。
有那种求着你想被签。
但是你说什么就不签的人。
对
我当然会有
体面的理由拒绝他了。
那实际的理由是什么呢？
就不适配
有时候真的不是因为他不够好。
就是我觉得我们公司没有能力。
像现在不一样
对 帮他做的更好了。
他可能去一个
我觉得那样的公司。
对 其实会更合适。
但这里确实需要一个双方的匹配。
我们得收个位
我们录了多久
还请久了
对 算久了
但是我感觉好像挺快的。
很快啊？
打打的
好 先为咋接呢？
没关系就可以这样。
不可以这样
谢谢大家
拜拜